wasn't it good hey guys you wanted to  know what i was binging right now  let's go  hey everybody i'm lee daniels i'm a  filmmaker and  i currently am binging well i'm not  currently binging i just finished  binging an incredible television show on  hbo max  called vaneno which i am not going to  even tell you about  you got to watch it for yourself to sort  of see also i'm watching i just  finished uh uh itina the  uh uh what do you call it it's a doc  which or gina turner which is incredible  so those are the two things i'm  currently watching  hi i'm lee daniels and drew thank you  for having me on  your show and everybody watch the united  states versus billie holiday  on hulu now